[Music]
so we all love cine steel 800 and
definitely nothing can replace the
feeling of shooting film but nowadays it
can get pretty expensive so in this
tutorial i'm going to show you how to
replicate the graduation effect with a
simple technique in capture one as you
can see i've already applied the brush
on multiple images and they work like a
charm i save these custom brushes so you
can get instant results and i will talk
about that later in the video including
a small contest so watch till the end to
find out more details
okay let's get started first step press
b to activate the brush tool and adjust
the size to match your preferences also
lower the opacity and flow to 70
then just paint in areas of high
contrast where the brightest meets the
darker areas
next go to the curve tab in the red
channel and just crush the white point
and there you have it
one thing that i don't like is the hard
edges on the lights it looks very
digital i want to have a smoother
transitioning right there so it looks
organic we can make this by creating a
new layer right click and copy the mask
from the first layer this way it will
only copy the mask and not the
adjustments applied on the mask
next step bring up the brightness and
make a ridiculous s curve to blow out
the highlights
now you can adjust the opacity of the
layer to control the effects
maybe adjust the luma range to further
refine the affected area
you can follow these steps to achieve
the hilation effect or i've saved a
couple style brushes for you to get the
same results instantly these brushes
also include light leaks to give your
images even more of a film look
you can find these brushes on my website
together with over 50 film presets which
will give you the same kind of look
linked down below or comment for a
chance to win them i'll choose a winner
at the end of the month like and
subscribe if you want to get more free
tutorials and thank you for watching
see you next time
[Music]
you